Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wo sind wir?
Wir sind in der Garderobe, der Cays, gehen gleich auf die Bühne. Wir wollen aber erst mal ankündigen, was wir als nächstes lesen.
Was wäre?
Wir bleiben Autoren treu. Wir haben schon mal ein Buch über Europa von Peter Stotadeig gelesen. Jetzt hat er ein Buch geschrieben über die großen Männer. Und zwar hat das den Titel Der Fürst und seine Erden über große Männer im Zeitalter der gewöhnlichen Leute. Und auf dem Cover kann man schon sehen, dass da ein Donald Trump ist, aber zugleich in einen Estuarschen Gewand. Wir werden auf das Cover dann auch noch zu sprechen kommen. Es geht also um die großen Männer in der Politik und was sie gerade bewirken oder verwirken. Wir werden aber noch ein zweites Buch lesen, nämlich Adrian Daub. Von ihm haben wir ja das Buch gelesen, was das Valley Denken nennt. Und jetzt hat er ein neues Buch geschrieben, was das Valley Herrschen nennt.
Theorien Paxis.
Ja, also wir sind sehr gespannt. Und das ist ja genau der richtige Ansatz jetzt, weil als das erste Buch rauskam, herrschten sie noch nicht in dem Sinne, dass sie im Oval Office laufen zu Gast waren und so eine Nähe hatten plötzlich zur Präsidentschaft, weil das damals noch die Biden-Administration war. Ja. Sie haben natürlich auch schon wirkmächtig gehandelt.
Genau.
Aber jetzt herrschen sie in einer ganz anderen Weise nochmal. Also ich bin sehr gespannt, denn wir fanden das damals sehr gut, das Buch.
Das Buch war sehr gut. Danach hat er sich der Känselkalscher gewidmet. Da haben wir da nicht so drauf geschaut.
Nee.
Und jetzt sind wir wieder zurück bei Adrian Daub.
Ja, das steht also bevor. Im aktuellen Salon, da aufweisen wir auch nochmal hin, kann man jetzt gerade zwei Besprechungen hören. Wir haben einmal das neue Buch Geld als Waffe von Ulrike Herrmann gelesen. Wir sind, so sagen wir, nicht begeistert. Wir haben sehr viel zu kritisieren, sehr, sehr viel. Und auch nicht begeistert, aber doch sehr aufschlussreich. Es war die Lektüre von Bibis Buch, Bianca Heinke, hat sich eine neue Personality zugelegt. Wir stellen fest, nee, das ist eigentlich noch die alte, nur ein neuer Gewand.
Vielleicht hätten wir im Titel schreiben sollen, dass es Baby Beauty Palace, nicht Baby Netanyahu ist. Leute, die fanden, das ist mir auch was danach aufgeschrieben.
Ja, ja, da waren wir.
Bibis Buch hab ich reingeschrieben.
Da haben wir so unpolitisch gedacht. Aber ja, natürlich.
So, was machen wir heute? Wir gehen gleich auf die Bühne und verabschieden den großen Denker Jürgen Habermas. Er ist tot. Ja, das ist schon, also klar, er ist sehr alt geworden. Er hat viel geschaffen, aber er hat halt auch Jünger sozusagen, wie jeder große Theoretiker. Und die versuchen auch nochmal, ihn zu verabschieden. Und über die macht man uns lustig. Nicht direkt über Habermas, sondern über die.
Aber ich kann trotzdem vielleicht auch ein paar würdigend kritische Worte zu Habermas gleichermaßen sagen.
Ja, total.
Ja, gut. Dann haben wir einen ganz großen Blog, weil ich doch dachte, ja, wir machen jetzt zwar häufig sehr Unterhaltsames, aber es ist doch jetzt wichtig, weil so viel passiert, über den Krieg im Iran zu sprechen. Deshalb, weil ich mal Diskurse nachzeichnen will. Also wir gehen einmal wirklich in den amerikanischen Abgrund, gehen also wirklich zu den Neonazis und wie die jetzt gerade diesen Krieg von Trump bewerten. Dann machen wir wiederum eine große Reise nach Deutschland zurück und schauen uns da die Diskurse an. Und zwar möchte ich kontrastieren Joachim Gauck und Tino Krupalla. Oh, gibt es noch einen Kontrast? Es gibt einen sehr deutlichen Kontrast. Und das Heikle ist ja wirklich, dass Tino Krupalla heute Abend zugestimmt werden muss in mehrfacher Hinsicht. Und dann natürlich auch wieder nicht. Aber das ist eben das Fatale, was ich gerade sehe. Also ich will es mal so sagen, ich habe die Befürchtung, dass die AfD, wenn sich dieser Krieg zuspitzt und die Folgen zuspitzen, dass die AfD einen neuen Anlauf nehmen kann, der sie wirklich zu einer Volkspartei macht. Also es ist eigentlich sehr dramatisch und das liegt aber genau auch an dem, was wir dann werden an dem anderen Diskurs von Joachim Gauck vertreten. Und dann fragen wir uns zum Schluss nochmal, ja, was können wir jetzt von den Versprechen halten, die März gegeben hat? Sind da keine Versprechen oder Ankündigungen? Er wird da nicht mitmischen. Wir hören da ganz kurz rein, wie Markus Lenz das verhandelt. Und es ist wirklich sehr dramatisch, aber ich fand es jetzt gut, darüber jetzt zu sprechen, weil in zwei Wochen oder zehn Tagen wir doch noch so viele andere Themen dazu beackern haben.
Okay. Und dann zum Abschluss muss Wolfgang heute ganz stark sein, denn wir gucken uns die neuen Bilder an, die die KI produziert. Und ich finde das wahnsinnig unterhaltsam. Ja.
Und du willst mir heute Abend sagen, dass ich jetzt schon Hollywood adieu sagen kann? Naja, du nicht.
Das Kino, das dich interessiert wird, ist ja schon seit Jahrzehnten Nische oder so bleiben.
Na komm.
Aber die großen Filme, die du natürlich auch würdest, allein weil sie große Filme sind und die aber auch jetzt nicht unbedingt oben listen bei dir, die kriegen natürlich Nahekonkurrenz. Und die Frage ist, macht die KI eigentlich irgendwas neu? Oder macht sie es noch einfacher? Ja.
Also ist das die Frage, die können wir auch zuspitzen, ist das das Ende von Hollywood oder das Ende von Michael Bay?
Ja, genau.
Das ist ja so deine Rubrik.
Es geht ganz konkret nachher auf Michael Bay.
Oh, da bin ich gespannt.
Gut.
Wer das hören will, kann das ganz einfach tun mit einem Abo. Dann hat man natürlich auch Zugang zu allen Live-Salons, die schon erschienen sind und all den anderen Salons. Das ist möglich, wenn man auf die Seite neuzwanziger.de geht. Dort ist der Button hin zu Steady. Wenn man schon bei Patreon ist, kann man auch darüber buchen oder ganz bequem mit dem iPhone bei Apple.
Genau. So ist es. Wir hören uns.
Bis gleich.
Ist alle bequem, ist es schön. Wer war mit uns gestern im Konzert? Ein paar Leute, ja, es war sehr voll. Dann ging es bis 2 Uhr nachts. Dann habe ich ein bisschen gechillt. Was hast du heute morgen gemacht?